I'd like to greet you at this conference
on non-conformism and dissent in the
Soviet bloc guiding legacy or passing
memory the conference is organized by
the Ukrainian Studies program here at
the harriman the east central european
centre at columbia the polish cultural
institute and the ukrainian museum of
new york and we would like to thank all
these organizations for bringing
together what I view is fascinating two
and a half days before us I also would
like to greet the general council of
ukraine so he both poha red shoe here
and I think it's also a sign of the
different world from the world of the
dissidents and nonconformists that we
can honestly greet the Ukrainian general
counsel here in the older days we were
more likely to see representatives of a
UN mission of the Ukrainian Republic
that was usually they're observing other
things than joining us in discussion so
the world has changed in that way I
think very very positively I have the
honor of introducing our speaker
miroslav marinovitch to you mr.
marinovitch was born in nineteen forty
nine in the draw hobbits area of ukraine
and when one looks at his cv his
biography today we would say it fits
very much the normal academic world of
this university that is one can see that
since the 1990s he's been lecturer
christianity of ukraine at the institute
of management in Brockovich then
director of the institute of religion
and society at the review theological
Academy then president of the Institute
of religion in society at the Ukrainian
Catholic University rising then to be
the vice rector of that university his
current position that we would say your
other normal academic
curriculum for someone who works on
religious studies a topic frequent today
and we see the distinguished list of his
fellowships including I think we are
honored to say ship here at Columbia
University the center of Human Rights
religion human rights and religious
freedom program and Inter shut an
internship at Emory studies at the
Catholic University of New Megan me
Megan in the Netherlands demarion during
her fellowship at the University of
would spark and I'm pleased to say being
from Canada Canada the colossi
fellowship at the Canadian Institute of
Ukrainian studies in Edmonton and his
distinguished list of publications
Ukraine at the margins of Holy Scripture
Ukraine a long way through the desert
something at least in a religious study
is a topic we would see various works on
human rights discussions of Ukrainians
and Jews and their paradigmatic models
of survival discussions on Ukrainian
idea in Christianity publications in
English on an ecumenical religion
Ukraine quite the normal publications of
someone at a major Catholic University
as the Ukrainian Catholic University
interview is and yet we know really this
is not the normal biography of an
academic because before those years when
we look at mr. marinovitch is passed we
find that as a member of the ukrainian
helsinki group from 1976 he was arrested
in 1977 and sentenced to 12 years 7
years in prison in the paramore blast
and then in exile in Kazakhstan he
didn't quite finish all those years
because the intervention of glasnost and
perestroika meant that at a certain
point he was released and then that very
strange phrase rehabilitated which i
always find so hard to say rehabilitated
before whom and why and who gave them
the right to rehabilitate that is his
courageous stand for human rights that
was non-conformism of that time and
inevitably drew people the descent was
part of his career that took him out of
a original education in rather technical
field in world and then brought him into
the world of the gulag of the Soviet
Union and then out into a world in which
he has concentrated on fu medical
religious and Christian issues and to
speak out on human rights it's really
quite a distinguished and interesting
career fascinating to us now to be able
to talk with them because i think is
this public assembles and looking at
various generations for some we are
really discussing a distant history for
some of our students now for many of us
here we are discussing a movement that
became central in our own lives I think
of the Ukrainian student associations of
the 60s and 70s whoo-hoo campaign so for
dissident movements of people one could
never dream you are going to meet and
now we can today then gather together
with so many of the distinguished
dissidents and nonconformists figures
whom we studied in New earlier and of
those of course one of our most
distinguished is our keynote speaker who
will begin the program that I think will
look into many of these issues in trying
to discuss what expectations were what
Rosie expectations were and what the
reality at times bitter has come in the
minds of the
who led that very important phase for
the three countries we will be looking
at for Russia Ukraine and Poland mr.
Mandela
thank you very much professor sisson
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
this conference is devoted to the
history of dissent in the former Soviet
Union and I as a former ukrainian
dissident would like to use this
opportunity to offer a special
introductory reflection it is my moral
duty and great personal privilege to
thank all those who made our mission
possible those who risked their
diplomatic or professional positions by
meeting with us in that Empire of evil
those who transferred our materials to
the free world the ones who helped other
voices be heard all those who gave us
their invaluable support here I mean
governments and ordinary citizens
diplomats and journalists editors and
media communicators cultural figures and
religious communities I mean people of
varied ethnic origins in my case
Ukrainian living in diaspora but also
those whose connection with Ukrainian or
Russian Baltic or caucus on occasion
cultures had been established simply
through human solidarity and compassion
let their efforts be blessed let their
support be never forgotten on behalf of
all former dissidents I would like to
express our deep gratitude to our
well-known and maybe still unknown
beneficiaries and ask you to be the
recipients and mediators of this
gratitude
the genesis of the Iranian dissident
movement was twofold predetermined by
the twofold nature of the Soviet regime
as at elect a totalitarian state and as
a Russian Empire camouflaged under the
communist Union on the one hand the
dissident moment was an attempt to
provide serious resistance to the
totalitarian state and aimed at the
democratization of the society in this
sense ukrainian dissidents shared the
position of all Soviet dissidents and
have the Russian human right circles in
Moscow as an example to follow and let
me say at the very beginning the support
by our colleagues in Moscow was just
invaluable at its early stages the cross
saga dissident movement had been fed by
the hopes generated by the debunking of
the so-called cult of Stalin after the
twenties a congress of the communist
party in 1856 and by a certain
democratization often addressed as
gustav so for a crisis of official
communist identity occurred the former
Stalinist ideological standards had had
been reconsidered and the official
history of the state had been rewritten
belief in the Justice of the Soviet
system had been injured but not fat
fatally the most active core of the
dissident moment at that time consisted
of optimistic and to some extent
idealistic communists
who wished distortions of the landing
official policy to be removed and the
existing system to be transformed into
communism with a human faith face on the
other hand the ukrainian dissident
moment derived its inspiration from the
liberation struggle of Ukrainians
especially strengthened in the first
half of the 20th century in some sense
it was a continuation of this struggle
but using different means the moment for
cultural religious and later civil
rights had objectively weakened the
Moscow colonial regime and therefore
promoted independent trends within
various nations subjugated this
liberation as that made Ukrainian like
Latonia Georgian and other dissidents
different from Russian dissidents who
often considered national movements
including the granion one to be not
truly democratic or polluted with
national nationalistic demands though
for the Ukrainian dissident movement
also included those politically oriented
figures for whom the struggle for Human
Rights and was a promising instrument
for achieving the main goal the
political independence of Ukraine rather
than a religion of a soul of their soul
they prefer even to use the term
resistance movement instead of dissident
movement they deliberately avoid
defining themselves as dissidents
referring to be addressed as political
prisoners or fighters for the
independence of Ukraine the Ukrainian
dissident
underwent several phases of development
the first one was the period of romantic
hopes and this started in the public
sphere with the foundation of free
cultural clubs at the beginning of the
sixties in cave and Eve Eve during their
discussion intellectuals cautiously try
to express opinions on literature and
culture which were different from the
official ones this period lasted until
the first arrests of 1965 used by the
government to put an end to dangerous
free thinking the second period could be
called a period of confusion and
depression after a certain phase of
public protests by the courageous
against arrests embarrassment and
confusion arose there was a hope though
constantly weakening that those arrests
were simply a mistake this period lasted
until the second wave of arrests in 1970
second 72 73 the third period was there
for the period of a reorientation of
course many people were disappointed and
felt despair because illusions about the
humanitarian evolution of the regime
were completely shattered while the
light at the end of the tunnel had not
yet appeared however the disposition of
dissidents had been radicalized and it
became clearly visible in the materials
of samba thou the Ukrainian replica of
the Russian son is that that is a
position literature illegally printed at
home on a typewriter cautious culture
illogical free-thinking had been
gradually replaced by the substantial
criticism of the regime and the ever
more resolute conclusion concerning the
inevitability of its changing and that
period is abroad the name Ukrainian
dissidents defined at a diverse group of
the not agreeing consisting of a
reasonable intelligentsia which dreamt
first of all about freedom of expression
human rights activists who responded to
the International Human Rights coal and
political fighters who expressed their
longing for the change of the regime and
for the independence of Ukraine the
fourth period of the dissident movement
in Ukraine may be called that of human
rights it was inspired by 1975 Helsinki
Accords between the organization of for
Security and Cooperation in Europe
members including the USSR the first
group for promoting the fulfillment of
housing of course was founded on may the
12 1976 in Moscow and the Ukrainian
Helsinki group was next it was founded
on November 9th 1976 by a group of 10
dissidents myself included headed by the
writer McCullough rudenko the group
publicized its declaration in Western
media claiming is purely human rights
non underground nature and following the
example of the Moscow group providing
names and addresses of its members very
soon it became clear however that non
underground groups were even more
dangerous
the Soviet regime than those underground
after three months of hesitation the KGB
decided to punish the Ukrainian Helsinki
group members for i quote spreading
anti-soviet propaganda aimed at
undermining the Soviet state and social
order and quote the crime considered
according to the USSR Criminal Code to
be the most dangerous state crime during
the next few years authorities arrested
eight ukrainian helsinki group members
myself included and expelled from the
country the other two the persecutions
had not frightened the non agree instead
they had mobilized a protesting portion
of Ukrainian society as a result during
the 1980s the group experienced two more
waves of kamikaze membership which were
inevitably persecuted today it is being
suggested that there were 41 Ukrainians
helsinki group members in total the
group had never announced its
dissolution and continued its activity
either in prison or abroad with the
whole period of ukrainian helsinki group
existence only one renunciation or less
burgnik and one suicide mahila magmic
took place on july seventh 1988 that is
during the type of Gorbachev's
perestroika some members of the
ukrainian helsinki group declared the
foundation of the ukrainian helsinki
union with clear political political
goals the ledger in fact was a prototype
of a political party
at the time of the Ukrainian
independence members of the nineteen
sixteen eighteen eighty Ukrainian
resistance movement had become
differentiated according to different
social political orientations those who
were working for change that thus it to
change the system had headed the
political opposition and made political
careers they became members of
parliament and leaders of political
parties the smaller portion of
dissidents again myself included refused
to take part in political activities and
continue to defend human rights or act
in the cultural or religious field
finally one more part of former
dissidents because of their age or
health problems miss drew from any
activity limiting themselves only to
participation in some approaching public
events the diversity of different
political orientations chosen by former
dissidents met brisk criticism later on
instead of one consolidated opposition
party it was a conglomeration of rival
groups United mostly around form a
dissident leaders who stood in
opposition to communists it was
considered by to be weakness or even
some responsibility for the dissident
movement because its diversity resulted
in conflictual divisions in fact the
dissident movement had never been
monolithic and therefore could not
satisfy all people's expectations indeed
dissidents were United first of all in
the non acceptance of the Imperial and
totalitarian
in a system though each of them saw the
future development of Ukraine
differently the importance of the
dissident movement at least in Ukraine
lies in the fact that just as a chemical
particle can crystallize an
oversaturated solution the appearance of
dissidents allowed the crystallization
of people's expectations and their
disobedience as Andrea Myrick accurately
said they dissident I quote quote made a
brilliantly simple thing in a country
that was not free they began to act as
free people and because of that started
to change the moral atmosphere and the
traditions that ruled the country and
quote their marriage in these are
invaluable and beyond doubt at the same
time unlike in the Czech Republic for
example Ukrainian dissidents had not led
their society to a final victory of
democracy victories they achieved were
partially temporary and the enormous
passionate energy was misused misused by
other political forces however in spite
of evident human weaknesses and failures
of the Ukrainian dissidents one cannot
pronounce a sentence upon them this is
because the third wave of
democratization according to Huntington
ran up against the invisible but very
real cultural wall which existed between
the two cultural civilizations I mean
euro-atlantic and euro-asian ones they
Iranian dissidents were not able to
overcome this role in principle
difficulties of such subsequent decays
lead me to the conclusion that the task
of all Ukrainians who want a better
country must lie in the creation of an
intermediary body that will not allow
destructive conflict to pull apart both
civilizations rather than in a
mechanical transfer of your Atlantic
models of democracy into a qualitatively
different Eurasian civilization this
would permit the fulfillment of a
two-fold task first in this way the
unity of the Ukrainian nation which is
predestined to exist on both sides of
the barricade barricade may be
safeguarded secondly by fulfilling this
national test Ukraine at the same time
may fulfill the civilization task of
harmonization of to cultural worlds now
let's turn to the topic of values of
dissidents and the present time today
Ukrainian dissidents may at the same
time be proud of the participation in
obvious National Democratic achievements
but also be in despair about not less
evident moral failures one of the most
important values supported by fighters
of the movement of resistance was
freedom civil national religious freedom
and the freedom of self-expression these
bowls were mainly achieved through
though everything can be understood
relatively until the year 2010 and the
level of civic freedoms
was much higher than that in Soviet
times in the country there was real
freedom of the press though it was based
not on the existence of the middle class
which is relatively weak in Ukraine but
rather on the reality of political clans
the big achievement of Ukrainian
democracy especially after the Orange
Revolution was a freedom of elections
though electoral legislation had some
hoes that made some falsification and
manipulation of voices possible finally
the fate of Ukrainian democracy seems to
be that of all week democracies as a
result of the year 2010 free elections
those who came to power are actively
changing the legislation to avoid losing
power in the future therefore weak
democracy has logically been transformed
into an imitative democracy violations
of human rights did not disappear they
only changed their character Ukrainian
authorities still traumatized human
dignity in a different way and that
leads to the diminishment of the scope
of people's rights and the level of
citizens responsibility corruption is
destroying the state system of justice
and the courts thus the former
dissidents cannot rest on their laurels
Ukrainian independence world was
achieved but due to different factors
the actual independence is considerably
weakened the inner inter-regional
differences that could become a richness
for state in harmony takes forms of
contradictions
that are hard to overcome these
differences are being abused by some
political forces who inside one part of
the nation against the other this also
influences the geopolitical position of
Ukraine because it happens to be divided
into two parts one part of Ukrainian
society has chosen a euro-atlantic
geopolitical orientation wanting to
legitimately join the EU and find a
shelter in a collective security system
first of all NATO from the New York
imperialistic aspirations of Russia
incidentally these is this is exactly
the position most dissidents identify
themselves with the other part of
Ukrainian society considers itself
belonging to the Russian Eurasian
cultural area this makes Ukraine more
vulnerable with its energy dependence on
Russia in this case the concept of the
geopolitical security of Russia does not
presuppose the true independence of
Ukraine inter inter-ethnic peace is
being maintained in Ukraine and the
freedom of ethnic minorities is mainly
safeguarded in this sense the goal of
the dissidents has been fulfilled
however the inertia of the previous
Soviet model Russian and
russian-speaking majority versus
non-russian minorities is still
considerably present according to this
model Ukrainians were discriminated
minority after 20 years of independence
Ukrainians have not succeeded in the
realization of their status of
ethnic majority and in safeguarding
their cultural rights in certain regions
in Ukraine that is in the east and south
of the country and in Crimea moreover
after the in the year 2010 elections the
counter-offensive of Russia speaking
Russian speaking politicians began to
take place in order to safeguard the
comfort of one language Russian regime
they demagogic Lee insist that there are
two official languages in Ukraine
Ukraine and Russia in addition these
political forces attempt to misuse
international mechanisms developed for
defending weaker or Rhenish vanishing
languages to safeguard the monopoly of
the Russian language which is strong
even without this ploy this not only
brings to nothing the expectations of
dissidents that in the independent state
Ukrainian culture and language will
develop freely the counter-offensive of
these russian-speaking extremes move
Ukraine away from balanced harmony
between the titular nation and ethnic
minorities which was also the dream of
dissidents I mean harmony of course one
of the most obvious achievements of
Ukrainian democracy was and hopefully
still is the progress in the sphere of
religious freedom thanks to some parity
between different religious and
confessional groups this frigging
demonstrated an ability for self
stabilization and self adjustment
certain dissidents
laid an important personal role in the
revival of previously persecuted
religious organizations and in
initiating inter-religious and
inter-confessional cooperation during
the year 2010 there was also an attempt
of pro-russian forces to turn this
situation back to the past by giving
some preferences to the Moscow patriarch
the idea of the Russian world developed
by patriarch Kirill the first of Moscow
is being used by the Moscow Patriarchate
against its and its supporters in state
authorities to make the Ukrainian
Orthodox Church of the Moscow
Patriarchate almost the established
church of ukraine and press back all of
its rivals religious rights of some
Orthodox rivals of the Moscow
Patriarchate are obviously violated
however I do hope that to put the
religions genie back into the bottle of
the third Rome will be most difficult
thus in many determinative parameters of
national existence the dissident mission
was successful enough but it has not
become irreversible and has not received
the necessary legislative and system
guarantees therefore the question of its
future importance for the nation is
still open there are two spheres however
in which this mission underwent deadly
failure the dissidents believe in
establishing the rule of law and in the
post-communist revival of social and
personal ethics
the injustice and immorality of the
Communist period has been copied under
different ideological slogans but at the
same time has even been strengthened in
certain areas the old mechanisms of
regulating injustice and immorality have
lost their efficiency but new ones have
not been developed the court system has
become the instrument of the ruling
authorities for settling accounts with
the opposition mass corruption
undermines the self-confidence of the
nation in the possibility of influencing
the course of events and make social
recovery possible the Orange Revolution
managed to revive the hope of part of
the nation in their own abilities but
not for long the solution is an old
slogan not to leave a lie remains a
dream in spite of all the treatments in
the sphere of freedom of speech modern
Ukraine does not leave the truth as we
mentioned before freedom of speech and
press is based on a variety of clams
each of whom according to its own
interests speaks only a part of the
truth adding some part of propagandistic
lie there for a whole set of semi truths
are interacting in the country and this
causes confusion among the people and is
accepted by them as one big untruth few
people in Ukraine nowadays believe in
the possibility of building a just
ordered the weakness of civil society
allows uncontrollable economic and
ministry misuse and the crisis of the
courts
system causes a feeling of being
defenseless thus the dissidents hopes of
establishing the rule of law have not
been fulfilled this raises a question
about the correctness of the dissidents
position taking after the collapse of
the Soviet Union in the matter of
bringing communists to justice for the
crimes of the communist regime in
retrospect we now realize that it was
not possible contrary to dissidence
beliefs to start with a blank page non
repentance for the sins of the
Communists and non punishment for their
crimes quite naturally resulted in
abuses of later administrations as a
result legal nihilism has developed in
the nation and the national discourse
easily adapts to clem loyal loyalty and
civility untruths and cunning behavior
are tolerated one more belief of all
this opposition also failed that is they
believe that post communist governments
would be wiser and more intellectual in
Ukraine doing nowadays intellectuals try
to formulate new and prospective
strategies of development but the latter
cannot be fulfilled because of the
closed nature of the ruling powers the
authorities use intellect only for their
political egos thank you very much
voices
voices of rare model authorities for
example the voice of your hands first
OOP are also less effective because of
the self isolation of the ruling elite
in the fortress of power these voices
are crying in the desert in vain the
weakness of their voices is caused not
because their nation allegedly does not
share their conclusions about the moral
degradation of the ruling ruling elite
according to some studies more than
fifty five percent of those surveyed
mentioned moral degradation at the main
reason for the present social problems
of Ukraine the real problem lies in the
fact and that people are not eager to be
in a position to legal and moral high
hidden handedness because it seems to
them that without people's solidarity it
would be too dangerous unprofitable and
consequently unattractive under these
circumstances Ukraine needs a new
solidarity civic movement a movement for
the implementation of the rule of law
and for the moral recovery of the
society the ability of former dissidents
to initiate such a movement is limited
some of them are too old others because
of political compromises of previous
years have ceased to be moral
authorities for the nation so the
question remains open as to who will
lead this in my opinion inevitable Civic
moment in the future instead we may
rather firmly state that former
dissidents laid down the main
precondition for that the life of
freedom during the last two
decades the Ukrainian nation moved
through a valuable school of freedom and
even if the experience achieved is
partially negative it is still
invaluable for the ability of the
individual to mature from the
totalitarian rise to the level of a
responsible citizen thank you very much
No
the college experience what extent with
you the human article ever communicate
with working
thank you actually is a history of the
dissident moment we know that there were
some groups oriented on workers and
they're actually represented by workers
but in general the human rights groups
are not so closed to the working class
there is some intellectual barrier
between that the two groups so
unfortunately I looking into the past
looking into the history of Polish
dissident moment it it's really a lost
opportunity thank
I wondering how Ukrainians students are
taught today about late so gay
is whether that's part of Institute's
how I school curriculum and or whether
there are any less formal ways in which
that distant
share the younger
it seems to me that there is a big
difference between the different part of
Ukraine's in teaching and studying in
this question it's not a problem enough
for Western Ukraine to know its history
of dissident movement and for example I
have a faculty of course at the
Ukrainian Catholic University which is
exactly named as the history of
liberation movement in the 60s and 80s
but it's rather difficult to organize
such courses in some high in some
universities in eastern Ukraine I or
especially Crimea or even practically
impossible to give such an information
at secondary schools it seems to me that
this history is still unknown and the
tendency is not to spreading this
information about our students but vice
verse about hiding I remember the
discussion with the head of archive
department in in Ukraine about the about
using these archives for explaining the
history of communism in Ukraine and the
head of this department is communist
itself is a communist woman
so she said actually it's it was
difficult history let's it's better for
us not to touch it so unfortunately
there were different phases phases in
this sense I remember and the attempt of
president leonid kravchuk to honor
ukrainian dissidents and political
prisoners who were rehabilitated by
paying some some money for them but it
was the whole idea transformed into
something very offensive because it was
at the time when the man you were
rapidly losing its value and I remember
that I just refused to go to receive
this money because it was just nothing
it was really offensive for four people
the resume at some stage the society in
the hole decided that well maybe it's
too much of dissidents because at the
beginning they they were they were
honored by being members of Ukrainian
Parliament and so on and this reaction
was very understandable for me because
I'm sure that the interest to this
dissident movement will be up and down
it's like it cannot be the same during
different periods of Ukrainian
development and now a very sort of
silent
untouched Ned otopeni and touch yes did
as far as I know dissidents are not
persecuted even for what they say but at
the same time they are not honored I'm
not sick City University of New York
from what we have heard in an excellent
presentation and from the questions that
have been asked it is quite clear that
Ukrainian dissidents and not only
Ukrainian dissidents but Georgian
dissidents and Russian residents have
been marginalized during the past 20
years this question has been addressed
by a number of speakers at our
conferences here at Columbia definitely
it was addressed by peril didn't know
firm also this question was raised in my
paper at our last conference and we
asked that we pay more attention to that
and that is to explore the reasons for
the marginalization of the former
dissidents in the Soviet Union would you
care to tell us that is your opinion
what are the reasons for this
development the sad development we would
say
it's it's very difficult for me to say
resolutely to say without any hesitation
that there is really marginalization and
that there is no marginalization the
truth truth is somewhere between the two
options I want to be sincere that I'm
not at the top of understanding of what
is going on in Ukraine so the society
may respect them but it doesn't mean
that society the society has always put
them in the center of their attention at
least it seems as a form of dissidence I
don't want to be in the center of social
attention exclusively for the fact that
I was arrested and being in the wars in
in detention now it is not only
responsibility for this is the
responsibility of society to owner those
people but also the responsibility of
those people Raul
to attract attention to be to be
politically realistic to be politically
important so it's there was possibility
of both sides according to my
understanding my name Henry weird and I
was three times the most maritime seen
you can but three times during Orange
Revolution I'm on tight election in
Ukraine I was in numbers and other
regions and I think that the most
important problem in Ukraine is the
problem of oligarchy aragaki or gallery
system that in danvers in the
appropriate appropriate roles in Kiev
them some groups of oligarchy which
govern Ukraine and to this time where
this regal he system will dominate
Ukraine it would reach it is impossible
to develop our democracy to this time is
the main important problem of Ukraine
that they try to develop democracy
bodies pressed by this alga hey sister
do you think what do you think about
this thank you thank you well the list
of main problems of Ukraine is seems to
be non exhaustive but you're right this
is one or very important in a problem it
is becoming more important now under the
new presidential administration because
according to my understanding the
activity of the middle class is being
suppressed in favor of Oleg Oleg arose I
may be wrong but it is my opinion I
cannot I'm
an expert in economy but at least what I
see is that people who managed to find
some way of existence due to their own
money their own efforts are now in big
trouble because of different means of
suppress so I would imagine the way when
big money of other oligarchs will work
for the society as for example
Rockefeller monies who work for the
American Society but I I don't don't see
the positive trends in this sense vice
versa I see the negative reaction Kathy
me pomnish opponent college I'd like to
pick up from a slightly different point
of view on professor camarones question
and ask you whether you see any younger
generation human rights activists who
are working perhaps on similar value
systems but indifferent using different
strategies perhaps using electronic
resources and who you consider to be
inheritors of the dissidents legacy it
seems to me that the whole situation in
Ukraine changed and
we cannot have such such a dissident
group now as we had in a previous time
because for me dissidents are possible
in a totalitarian state and we
definitely have known totalitarian
system in Ukraine now we have some human
rights group groups for example as in
hockey Harkov human rights group which
is very powerful very professional I I
just admire their activity there are
some other groups and what about what is
very important and optimistic for me in
present Ukraine is the knowledge how
democracy works the knowledge of young
people among young people let me tell
you one story during the presidential
administration of low need kuzma I was
very angry on young people who were part
of human rights seminars organized by
Western countries including the United
States and no visible results of that
the countries is still authoritarian and
young people are silent I remember one
seminar when I just exploded and I said
very strong words to young people but
later during the Orange Revolution it
was very clear that actually we have a
different generation already
we have generation educated in the
present system models of democracy I
remember many young people from eastern
Ukraine came to the Ukrainian Catholic
University for Christmas together action
organized by us and we had a discussion
of the positive and negative sides of
you or enjoyable other or orange
revolution I remember I was ready to
organize the discussion to explain some
things I prepared some analysis nothing
was needed excellent understanding of
democracy no matter from what region
young people came Donetsk or leave loot
or other other places of Ukraine so I
was really impressed by that this is our
hope tender Gregory Anka of the trigger
and commendation I would like to
continue about the prospective of the
new generation you know that I'm now
just visiting he crane first time I was
allowed to eat in 92 and visited several
times and my impression was a kind of
contradictory looking at the younger
generation I just give probably a couple
of examples when i arrived in 92 in cave
everybody spoke Ukrainian this Russian
accent but doesn't matter that everybody
try to spot Ukrainian then I returned
what three years later killed spoke
Russian again and it was not much of the
pro-ukrainian film from
but then I returned again another few
years I didn't take all exactly keys to
was mostly Russian speaking but now the
Russian speaking people were associated
themselves to Ukraine and considered
themselves to Ukrainian and that I
should probably also mention that as you
know that ethically that Ukraine
actually that monolithic in a way but
part of the Ukrainian a Ukrainians are
as in speakers and this complicated
situation by itself and you said that
countries are western and eastern part
of a different on south and part you
know that again I don't know that for me
more difficult to judge yet yeah I know
that is in hockey Nora Barry speak
Russian practically but if before in the
Soviet Union I was just in before I was
forced to leave I came to keep this is
it and I asked a because i could not
much time I unasked in line waiting for
the taxi in Ukrainian who is the last in
and the last person stop cursing me
inertia and saying that to speaker human
language and that's definitely changed
now when i first visited the last time I
just try to be a proctor I just try to
speak in Ukrainian
Kharkiv and Kiev and everybody tried to
ask me in Ukrainian or some people
apologize that they cannot speak
Ukrainian an answer in Russia and vice
versa because people are saying that
then relief is impossible to speak
Russian you probably remember and I just
ask somebody created in Iraq or
something and the details in Russian by
the way so that one time driving to that
on the other hand is some conversations
with younger generation I notice that
what was difficult for me in myself my
own evolution to write a fun distinguish
that we should prevail that from might
fall but the war should beware and on
the other hand there is another part of
my prolonged equation that also we know
that house divided cannot stand and
that's still present even whatever good
feeling can even do a year of works
everywhere but this still seems to me
that it's my passion it's a little bit
us from outside that those understanding
of a divided house and we were really
hopeful or how to some of the younger
generation and
I understand that dissidents just
getting cold and we all getting hold of
it then they just died out slowly but
and of course country is different and I
would like to know what is your view
from inside what the prospect for the
younger generation to pray country to
the civilized world in a way are sorry
for that phrasing thank you it seems to
me that the main problem of Ukraine is
not in the fact that some Ukrainian
speak Russian some Ukrainian and vice
versa the main problem of your grain is
that this difference is being misused by
the politicians and to one part is being
directed against the other part it's
very clear now for example when the new
Minister of Education metro tabachnick
is being curtailing diminishing the
sphere of usage of ukraine ukrainian
language just in under under the pretext
of
existence of the russian-speaking
population and that their rights has to
be safeguarded I'm absolutely aware that
rights of russian-speaking population of
Ukraine russian-speaking Ukrainians and
Russians have to be safeguarded and I'm
as a former dissident i'm in favor of
that but I am I don't want I don't like
the injustice is being presented to the
society in the form of justice let me
explain you know the stadium the running
it's like running Drex different running
tracks so if you have the finish line
the only one for each runners then you
have to put start starting points on
different place because they run
difficult different distance so what
tabachnick wants now in Ukraine to put
to draw the line for start and finish at
the same for all runners Ukrainian
language runs more distant track and it
has to have some for some some margins
of appreciation
saying in human rights worthy in that
case it would be just without that just
we have Russian and Ukrainian population
we have to have Russian and Ukrainian
lab language languages equally state
languages no this is wrong this is
against the human rights balance
explained the uniqueness of the new
draft of the law presented by the Metro
tabachnick of a new Minister of
Education draft of the law about
language situation he said that it is
normal for European countries that the
majority ethnic majority tries try to
impose its language on other minorities
but it is uniqueness for your when the
country tries to diminish the level of
usage the state language that the
official language of the country in
favor of other languages so even he you
may Commission EV your diplomats are
against that draft of the law because it
violates the harmony is a society young
people speak both languages so I don't
see I don't see some if politicians do
not intervene then young people will
find a solution for linguistic problem
in Ukraine let me let me say in short
thank you a victor barbershop perform a
dissident and our half of intellectual
dissent started in keep in military
school like this point and a former
graduate of it was great Center who was
in previous government minister for
depends what M intriguing i'm following
the question of henrik about oligarchy
role but a more intrigued with
comparison of current situation and
ukraine and in Russia where preach Gina
or near Bolsheviks or near cheek ism in
putinism is taken you know fault and we
knew the role of KGB as old dissidents
it wasn't really Communist Party tercer
who was our counterpart it was KGB
tercel and NT but was a vicious source
as it was in Leningrad in the old time
and my comparison is that in Russia we
see how a llegar become near oligarchs
by chickies and I'm unticked in your
water all as institution KGB in new
shape is you know playing a role and you
know in Ukraine and current Ukraine and
do you feel do you do you sense
regardless things there is no political
prisoners from no political prisoners
and rudra but we do know that it's
really say it's not a deterrent state in
Russia it's also a champion village of
democracy and non patella tarrant state
but it's to me it's deja vu and the pale
of Russian dissident or of dissidents in
that respect was not was ignoring the
problem of really our counterpart as on
top of course the kak to be leader we
really ignore a debt where the enemies
of us and who persecuted us not the
Communist Party people say and I'm
talking it on the basis of how to say
that I'm definitely both from keep and
then in general stuff
Moscow with our group of union union of
intellectual freedom we are talking
about intellectual freedoms less
concerned about KGB but being military
cadet and working on par with military
intelligence we knew how a rivalry of
the institution and one of the
institution in Russia become a dominant
force so what what you think is there is
any potential danger or cryptic danger
of the institution like KGB or over them
so it seems to me that there is a clear
difference between the situation in
Russia and Ukraine in this sense in
Russia HB or fazbear is a clearly ruling
party clear ruling force it is not the
case in Ukraine yet but I think that is
too many differences in our social or
political order I don't think that we
will have the the same sedation during
the presidency of Houston Chrome I was
really impressed that the as balloons
replica of KGB who opened the archives
of the difficult periods of Ukraine
including hollow tomorrow and I'm
pleased to say that panvel edema rocket
ravitch is present here his one of the
figures which was
we are thankful for them for opening
these archives it was very important
then when the new presidential
administration came to power and there
was a clear message sent by the fact
that one historian Ruslan zabili was not
allowed to sing simply it was not
allowed to use some may historical
materials archive materials which
suddenly again closed mean I told you
about knew about the Communist
administrator of archives in in Ukraine
archive department of Ukraine and in
general it seems to me that a new head
of as though mmm security forces in
Ukraine is trying first of all to
monitor the protest potential of
Ukrainian society he is one of the two
untouchable in Ukraine to untouchable
officials in Ukraine according to social
opinion we have two persons that cannot
be removed without permission of Moscow
it is horoscopes key as a head of s
burrow and Metro tabachnick is a
minister of education so they they have
a special mission approved by Moscow
partners of the present presidential
administration but anyway I repeat that
I don't think that we will have the same
the similar situation in Ukraine with
the role of security forces as it is in
Russia thank you zaretsky from New York
University and also the Center for US
Foreign Relations mr. metal knowledge
because mr. Reid's brought up a
important issue something that was
actually asked by somebody initially I'd
like to follow up on that and then also
very shortly on about the youth in the
future so something in the past and then
something in the future it may help in
terms of the conference tomorrow and the
next day and that is you when it came to
Ukrainian dissidents there seemed to
have been as a result this may have just
been history of working itself out in a
terribly totalitarian system but the
dissonance had a hard time being able to
as a result of their sort of isolation
at our time being able to finally bring
the story to the masses or to the
naughty probably tuna not heed that
relationship was an uneasy one you did
explain that some of some of those
dissidents did eventually become
political leaders who certainly came out
of that but I'm wondering even when with
things like Solidarity trade unions a
religion renewal of religious movements
and so on so forth the dissonance had an
enormous moral authority and at some
point in not taking on that moral
authority in 92 95 period they did allow
in a way the combs
small element the younger chromosomal
element to come into play some of it
became oligarchs but some of it even in
terms of the not more modern orange
democratic movement we saw some of that
old consumo the the taste of that with
remained even amongst Democratic leaders
who I happen to have seen lasts the last
10 years I've run into many of them and
I've seen that the Pope consumer
attitudes were not able to get washed
that easily I was wondering what
happened in that 92-95 period that the
dissidents did not take on more of the
responsibility of what we used to call
in the not eat the responsibility of
being a prophet now second you gave a
very good point that the youngsters now
seem to have done this past or
post-orange they have now learned
democracy on their own and they're so
well educated that they may be doing
what they are up street is to thing in
fact it's doing so chaotically that
there seems to be no leadership is it
possible now this is a second question
is it possible that the Ukrainian
dissidents because they are still in
available can day in the moral morass
that the oligarchs and the old
chromosome Archie have created in
Ocarina can the dissidents still play a
role in the future or is this something
that basically is left is left for
history and only history can can devise
something Oh Lord
that's the first of all he seems to me
that dissidence really had some moral
authority at the beginning of the
nineties but they are they didn't have
enough political power to realize their
goals I mean political goals even to
review the one of the most prominent
political leaders of Ukraine of that
time clearly had had real difficulty in
imprison ting in winning hearts in
Ukrainian society too many people were
afraid of this Democratic nationalist
movement and you have to understand that
for too long in eastern Ukraine in
southern Ukraine the very the very fact
that you speak Ukrainian was to label
yourself as a nationalist I remember
that feeling inkay you when I I failed
to find a work a job for myself I saw
the announcement that they need someone
to be hired I came and I propose myself
but said that in Ukrainian and
immediately I said no no
I was told no no no thank you we don't
need any more so the nation was raised
new generations were raised in the
understanding that it is too dangerous
to Steven to speak about some Ukrainian
history crane in future independence and
and so on so that's why so many people
were they were impressed by the new
democratic movement at the beginning of
the 90s they followed for the events
with very big interest but they were
afraid so that's why the model of
Lynette Kravchuk independence but with
communists in power was very attractive
for those people and the second part
about kind of dissident still a row must
a yard Oh in the future of
yes that but that was the moment when I
said Oh Lord none on the one hand I feel
some respect among young people as a
former dissident but it seems to me that
dissidents in general lost the key to
hearts of young people there is
something in their minds which is coded
in a different way than we got it and I
I personally and we cannot decode this
secret of young people it seems to me
that probably we will remain respectful
but I would really be surprised if it
would be dissidents who will initiate
the transformation of society political
transformation there is some possibility
that they will be influential and
powerful in the sense of moral authority
yes in this sense there is some
possibility but not maybe in political
comment about my job hey
and my aunt said
time is drawing to a month first I'd
like to say that although this is
declining studies problems legend first
in our first lecture was on Ukrainian
business this is the our goal is to try
and be as comparative and discussing
these I think we have had a wonderful
start of this that is a tour de force of
telling us the entire developing to be
pregnant dissident movement and then
bringing us up to current affairs and I
think we will be returning to that in
these comparative discussions if I did
this absence I didn't take the chairs
prerogative and ask the question I think
one thing it was very much on my mind
and I like perhaps in another discussion
reservoir of knowledge could tell us
that it's the combination of these
religious values and this is improvement
when it comes in days duration and how
that relates the dissidents
non-conformism and also his eastern and
western ukrainian art or western ukraine
lithuania and a few other places being
quite different from the rest of the
sony
and more like Poland in many ways just
got in that religious issue i think
played the roles i will add that I for
those we're so happy that so many of you
could attend I made a few remarks in the
beginning about the organizing
institutions who are of course
institutions don't organize people
organized standing and hovering in the
back east dr. Marco and relationship who
is the heart soul of the organization I
will now ask if he has in the
announcements who would like to Vegas to
other than tomorrow we start in his room
at nine-thirty with our first panel but
now we have a reception
and we like to thank us for what